joining us radio talk show host with
radio America and author Dana lash also
foxnews contributors tommy'll Erin
Jessica Tarlov here's a fact six times
there's going to be a sixty portation
they wouldn't hand him over to the
federal government who had requested
that they hand this man over did this
sanctuary city law kill Kate Steinle
well the illegal immigrant himself is
the one who killed Hilla - you allowed
him to stay here and I think that there
will be a sea change in this we thought
in Virginia with the race Ralph Northam
came out again sanctuary cities I
believe it was key in him wedding night
without sanctuary cities in all
likelihood Kate Steinle would be a
lifetime without the same San Francisco
sanctuary city policy a lot too many
people there i all she was 32 to 33
years there alive borders of so porous
that a man can sneak back in a six time
or seven times there but we know that we
have a net outflow of they're not wanna
build a border I will never want to
build a little relative water effective
if you want to put more Bibi Netanyahu
Bibi Netanyahu swears it is changed
Israel I've seen it and the United
States are very different our borders
are different go innovate I do not
believe that there are a number of
Republicans who don't believe that if
you talk to a Republican congressman in
Texas they say that is not the case you
want to put more agents there and family
go - let me go - Tommy learn Tommy your
thoughts well to answer Jessica's
question they're physical barriers work
and that's why Democrats don't like them
but Democrats are gonna be put in a very
interesting situation now they're gonna
have to choose between illegal
immigrants and the American people and
I'm anxiously awaiting you know the
response of the Democratic Party because
I think it's going to really help us in
2020 Dana like you I've been firing I've
been using firearms since I'm young he
said he was aiming this at a sea animal
and then it became I stepped on it and
then it did ricochet and hit Kate
Steinle in the back this particular Sig
Sauer it's not one that I fired I was
wondering if you have
I have and I thought what Dan Vaughn
Gino said earlier was pretty spot-on I
thought that the defense was moronic on
this and I realized that Shawn that
there are certain things that the jury
saw that we the people didn't see but I
do find it interesting that the same
people who want to look at ballistics
and forensic reports as it concerns
ballistics they ignore that in the Mike
Brown case look and for the lawyer to
also invoke Donald Trump and then
falsely also say that there's some sort
of that there's an investigation that
was based on Kremlin propaganda which
sub-state substantiated a FISA warrant I
thought was bizarre
this is moronic people in California are
not protected the courts have said that
there is no justice no peace for the
law-abiding those who break the law and
enter illegally are given preference
over law-abiding Americans and
California has now declared itself to be
a dangerous State Shawn California has
decided that it wants to make it
virtually impossible for law-abiding
Americans to be able to choose their
pro-choice right of self-defense
you know the feminists equalizer a
boomstick but if you're an illegal alien
and you are in that state being
protected by it as a sanctuary state
well then you're afforded all of the
luxuries of American citizens including
rights that we have sacrificed for due
process and you're given a slap on the
wrist that this wasn't even involuntary
manslaughter isn't a front to due
process it's an affront to justice and
all the law-abiding citizens in
California is shameful this system
failed on so many different levels if
I'm president Trump tonight I'm saying
no federal dollars to any city any state
like California that says and you just
said to me you agree sanctuary city law
wasn't is in existence this Court would
likely be alive tonight so my question
is why should the federal government
give one penny to any city that doesn't
want to obey the laws of this country I
think that all sanctuary cities should
cooperate with ISIF and if they don't
really not give them federal dollars
yeah that's a whole other debate and I'm
sure the president will be too reason
why we should not president Trump I'm
saying not a dime to these cities well
there's a lot that that money gets used
for that it's not just for sanctuary but
if you're going to allow criminals
seven-time felons mayors in sanctuary
cities all over this nation are paying
attention to what happened today
okay I'm gonna hold my feet mark that's
not gonna bring back Kate Steinle it's
not and it's an absolute tragedy we've
been saying that from the beginning I
mean you're gonna get the 11 million
illegal immigrants who are here out of
the country that you're going to get rid
of a policy that a number of Republicans
have back including Rudy Giuliani who
said that we need to make sure that
people can come out of the shadows to
cooperate with law enforcement let me go
to Tommy well as someone that is
actually residing in California right
now I can say as a young woman living in
California this sends a very clear
message to me and that is illegals are
protected in this state and Americans
are not and these I think that jessyca
her heart is probably in the right place
but anytime you defend sanctuary cities
especially after this verdict has come
out I have to ask you why would you
still defend a policy that is harboring
criminals that's the end of the
discussion it's not oh there's a lot to
look at here that's a question when you
when we have a national tragedy and we
have Dana on the panel who's a firearms
expert when we have a mass shooting we
don't say we need to take away all the
guns because someone misses you all the
time they don't say we'll take away all
our guns we want 94% of Americans I have
to interject well please
you know law-abiding Americans are
always blamed for the actions of
criminal thugs like Zarate this
individual who murdered Kate Steinle
law-abiding Americans who our Second
Amendment practitioners are constantly
blamed for the actions of repeat
offenders like this illegal alien but
yet when the illegal alien does it oh it
was an accident he meant to shoot a seal
if only law-abiding Americans got as
much courtesy and and and were afforded
that as much as this individual was it's
never going to happen but now you can
understand why so many law-abiding
Americans are so disgruntled at this I
got to let you all go sad night thoughts
and prayers with this family
this system failed this family in this
young girl